turning officer for the new Helena and
year parliamentary constituency give
notice that the number of votes recorded
for each candidate is as follows young
karmak part a crystal Mahalo per earned
Vela in here Tiger saw John Carmack
Scottish Christian party proclaiming
Christ's lordship 1108 Ellison Eagle
Party LeBrock malapa quick Muller
agasshi ax al-assad MacDonald Scottish
Labour Party 5006
a nurse Briana McNeil party Nash
internal oppa Shia Milla
I guess tree jerk Angus Brendan McNeil
Scottish National Party SNP 6013 Daniel
Stephen McCroskey
Torian I guess Lutheran are in Halawa
Davila k appeared Daffy da he hits Ahern
Daniel Stephen McCroskey Scottish
conservative and unionist 2441 Seamus
mcfar Vic liberally gomorrah doc Mahalo
/ da he had died he hits a Jake James
Patterson Scottish Liberal Democrats 250
vote three Fickett sir nine pine shocked
Amaka circuit the turnout was sixty nine
point seven percent Baku ik Giachetti
hit paper and voter Aaron Aaron alt
there were 35 rejected ballot papers
agus motion amia jariabek you've L
Ernest Brian and McNeil Aaron hug Marvel
Parliament air Sun rain as a rain thing
in the Helen and Ania and I declare that
Angus Brendan McNeil is duly elected to
serve as Member of Parliament for an
aquiline and aeneas constituency
[Applause]
you